martiniquaise martinique nous vivons
dans un monde prometteur
et inquiétant à la fois prometteur dans
tous les azimuts de la technologie et le
la science la réalité dépasse la fiction
dans un futur relativement proche
nous conduirons plus la voiture c'est la
voiture qui nous conduira et pourtant
sans être pessimiste
nous ressentons combien les raisons
d'espérer sont fragilisées face aux
inquiétudes de toutes sortes
nous mesurons combien la démocratie est
menacée par la montée de l'obscurantisme
nous constatons que l'épanouissement de
la matinée se heurte à des comportements
rétrogrades
notre pays n'est pas en dehors de ces
réalités ni non plus je ne peux pas
c'est la vie l'appareil
d'où nos toits vigilance à ne pas
admettre le roi tout d'intervention
militaire dans cette zone ce qui serait
une catastrophe supplémentaire face à
l'hôtel entre à prévoir l'avenir de
façon sereine où elle aime de
l'aléatoire ce constat valable pour vous
l'êtes aussi en maints endroits du monde
en effet la belgique mais des conditions
de la vie améliorée c'est le retour en
force des sectarismes des menaces pour
la paix et la sécurité
les espoirs mis dans la démocratie qui
libérerait dans la technologie qui
égaliserait dans la science qui
fraternisent
son démenti par les violences les
disparités et les aiguiller chers
compatriotes le besoin de confiance en
nous mêmes est primordial pour suivre la
voie maintenant vers plus de dignité et
de responsabilité et susciter le respect
les autres cet espoir routière le
souffle novateur de la jeunesse notre
société peut être solidaire envers tout
ce que la vie handicap chemin faisant et
respectueux du droit de chacun par la
société misogyne pas de société
l'ostracisme martiniquaise martiniquais
ne devions pas d'un iota visons la
réussite
chacun apportant sa pierre à l'édifice
bonne année à vous tous petits et grands
ont l'année 2019